verbotene liebe der pulle und das ghetto
arbeitslos und spaß dabei germain schira
und stefan genießen das leben ohne
rücksicht auf gesetze doch dann ist es
bei einer festnahme gewaltig zwischen
germain und einem jungen ordnungshüter
es klingt nach einem
hollywood-blockbuster war klar dass ich
glaube ganz kurz
ihr wisst schon dass es freibäder gebt
ihr müsst jetzt nicht in so einem
brunnen eigentlich baden rauskommen ist
ihr vorhaben mit der bahre veranstaltung
ich habe eine bürger meldung dass ein
verstoß gegen die gemeindeordnung so
einmal nachgeben hat hier warum habe ich
diese dritte auf wir haben den verstoß
gegen die gemeindeordnung für dich bitte
raus was
dass er verbitte ich mir was macht ein
vorbildlicher ebay user verbieten
steht wegen verbieten also bitte
könnt ihr nochmal kurztanz sehen
[Musik]
ich glaube die hat viel größere probleme
als dass da gerade die polizei vom
brunnen steht
[Musik]
mit
großes sonntag
nichts kochen dann bestell dir was dann
kaufte ihr geld jetzt ist ja ich habe es
gesagt ich habe es gesagt hollywood ist
nichts gegen hilf mir für auf ok er hat
und die weg und erst wahrscheinlich hat
er sich in sie helga
das wird jetzt krieg ich nehme sie jetzt
fest
[Musik]
es ist nicht immer frage ist dürfen die
das überhaupt
somit polizeiuniformen dass dieser so
schlecht darstellen nicht mehr
polizisten sind gehalt polizisten
irgendwie war das komisch als ich sie an
die wand gedrückt habe
vielleicht wie willst du dir auch mal
nicht während der arbeit gegen die wand
drücken
das einzige was ich gegen die wand
wer das im bmi nicht gerade fördert
aufpassen müssen sich jetzt ja ganz
ruhig ganz kurz und beleidigen die da
die ganze zeit rum ich traue mich nicht
mal wenn ich an den polizisten her laufe
auf mein handy zurück oder ich denke ich
mache etwas falsch und die beleidigen
die da im höchsten maß ganze die ganze
zeit dann beleidigt jetzt hoffen wagen
so die jetzt jedoch wir sind jetzt
vernünftig habe ihr ehrenwort okay
lassen sie jetzt los okay das auch das
wichtigste
das ehrenwort
wenn man vor gericht ist und man hat
eben eine straftat begangen kann man
auch einfach sagen ich mache es nicht
nochmal ihren wort und dann seid ihr so
mit dem richter
dann geht es ganz schnell
das was hier gemacht haben ist ein
verhalten das muss ich ja wohl ein und
konnte so nicht bringen wenn wir gegen
sie eine anzeige ist ganz nur ihr der
aussage die halle mich bist du am
liebsten per lastschrift ist jetzt
kriegt er die daten von ihr schreibt das
auf dann ist hier mit alles notiert so
dann kommt ihr da heinz-peter plötzlich
dann bei der dienste an und sage
rapunzel macht man jetzt dein haar
herunter
und vielleicht noch
nachdenken was der kollege gerade gesagt
hat und dass man ein bisschen auf sich
wirken lassen ja ja willst du nicht
mitgehen und da ein bisschen mit wirten
beim überlegen
lassen sie sich auch
sie legen
kann es sein dass so komplett dumm bist
ja ich glaube ja ja ja mal sehen ich
hasse die polen so nämlich hinter
ähnlich
dieser zeit war echt niedlich also ja
und obwohl du mich ja gar nicht gesehen
hast
[Musik]
ich hatte keinen guten tag ich würde da
gerne wien einweisen
[Musik]
respekt geht bei der germain
ganz ganz groß geschrieben darüber steht
sie läuft das halt ich kenne junge dame
von der sie beruhigen zu können
[Musik]
ich will jetzt wirklich kein nagel an
die offene tür hängen aber ich fühle
mich hier ein bisschen wie in seinem zug
[Musik]
ich komme jetzt drohen sie mit und da
kann sie mir erzählen was sie wollen
ich komme jetzt rum und nehmen sie mit
er fragt man sich dann auch nicht mehr
warum
na holla die waldfee da brennt auch die
luft und dann das
na holla die waldfee da brennt ja die
luft
so eine scheiße ich hoffe das kommt dem
ok nicht um sagt auch mensch
wichtig
einfach mensch bleiben
das
hatte ich jetzt so dann auch
lang nicht mehr an der stelle mich das
heutige video allerdings am ende meine
lieben freunde wenn ich meine hilfe
reaction hier gefallen hat das kann
einen daumen hoch unter dem video dann
schreib mir unten die kommentare was ich
als nächstes reagieren soll und muss ich
glaube ich nicht sagen bist selber dass
er da nachholbedarf hat
[Musik]